SPEAKER 1: I am ready
to take my DevOps
career to the next level.
SPEAKER 2: Have you considered
Google Cloud Professional
DevOps Engineer certification?
SPEAKER 1: Tell me more about
the DevOps engineering role
itself.
SPEAKER 2: A professional
Cloud DevOps engineer
is basically responsible
for efficient deployment
operations, balancing service
reliability and delivery speed.
They are skilled at
using the Google Cloud
tools to build CICD pipelines
and monitor and manage them.
SPEAKER 1: Are
there prerequisites
to approach the exam?
SPEAKER 2: It's
recommended that you
have about three years
of industry experience,
including maybe one year of
managing solutions on Google
Cloud.
SPEAKER 1: Any advice on
where I should I get started?
SPEAKER 2: There are tons
of training resources,
from sample questions
to hands-on labs
and on-demand courses.
Check them out.
And did I mention
you will receive
a digital badge, an online
certificate, and swag?
[MUSIC PLAYING]